when it comes to political sound by
strong and stable is sir last decade in
2020 it's all about levelling up Boris
and coordinates on the northerners who
lent fervor in the last election he
promised he's going to level up the
regions and best that pesky Westminster
bubble once and for all a constitutional
review will be launched in the spring
and amongst other things we'll explore
the House of Lords relocating to York
I'm a massive fan of boosting the law
and talk of relocations gets my verts in
fact I'd go a step further and relocate
birth houses not just the second chamber
alas if they're serious about levelling
it up then any relocation needs to be an
addition to a serious program of reform
for the House of Lords and as for the
regions they'll also need property
volution plans improved investment tax
incentives better education and enhanced
transport links only then will the north
truly reach the dizzy heights of the
next level I'm gonna say something I
don't often say on the show I'm
absolutely open-minded about this and
I'm going to be persuaded by what I hear
from my fellow pledge panelists because
the argument for is absolutely obvious
not least that the government is only in
power because it's borrowed the votes of
so many of you so it has to be seen to
facilitate that I don't about the House
of Commons but the House of Lords I
think possibly is a very good idea save
for the fact that and this is why I
would argue against it against the House
of Commons the very fact that the house
bombs is in London is because it is the
capital city which also attracts all the
financial institutions and most of the
relevant bodies Scotland Yard mo D
counter-terror whatever it might be in
moments of great crisis I think
certainly for the Commons it makes sense
that the commission of the Met can be
there like that as can the governor the
Bank of England or what it whatever it
might be so that is why I think a
capital city has to do that so I'd
always argue against I'd always arguing
films as for the Lords I think it's
probably but I want to listen everyone
else probably a good idea and I rather
like the fact that his Lord or his
ladyship will have to get on a train to
claim their hundreds of pounds of
allowances and
no nails and some of the best best um
pensioner care you can get in the world
by sitting there and being paid for the
privilege they'll let you have to get on
a train to go to York so I'm even-handed
but I'm probably tilting towards you
yeah I think this is great idea I think
you know a lot of these piers are very
keen to turn up in the brexit debates
you know they're very happy to remain in
the EU and remain in London let's get
them out of London I know that it is
symbolic but a lot of politics is
symbolic we have this massive problem in
this country is that we have a capital
city we don't really have a second city
no offense to Birmingham but it's not
like Madrid and Barcelona or New York
and Chicago we don't have a second city
as such and we need to do things that
start to facilitate that and you know
Mike were also talking about cancelling
hs2 now it's imperfect and apologies to
anyone who lives in Aylesbury as well
but what comes in its place you know in
this you look at the over 62 corridor
all those big cities up there in the
north we know if you want to go in this
country up and down you're fine
then immediately it's a problem and yeah
there is a part of me Nick they're quite
likes the idea of seeing how they get
there per diems yeah if they have to get
on a train I think it's a bit of a
gimmick I mean I think that the real
issue which I completely agree with is
that we don't have a second city that
we're not properly investing in the
north of England I take that seriously
like we need something that replaces the
industry that used to make towns in the
North line and we've never had a serious
long-term political consensus around how
to build up those cities back into
economic powerhouses listen to people
who North about the northern powerhouse
they're a scathing about it absolutely
scathing and I think that sounds like a
wrestler I have not had good feedback
from people I speak to in northern towns
about northern power so I think if we're
serious about that then this kind of
sounds quite superficial in comparison
it I mean yes politics is symbolic so
yeah maybe it does send a good message
but what I see happening is that we
relocate the House of Lords to north we
promptly kind of forget about it and and
it it becomes every time someone says
but we're not doing anything from North
to say what we put the House of Lords
there
and it doesn't read okay it's really
nice as well I think proximity matters I
think that actually when you are close
to something it becomes harder not to do
something about the problem and though I
think this the problem would be it then
becomes somewhat unfair if the House of
Lords is just moved to another city what
about the other cities and I think a
model that would be much more
interesting is something similar to what
happened with the BBC and also what's
happening with channel 4 which is you
have regional hubs and actually why do
we need another House of Lords in one
place why don't we split it up a bit and
then they come to London once a month or
whatever together it's earned without a
bit you've seen the EU Parliament didn't
you and you know they relocate whistles
Strasbourg and that gets absolutely
hammered in terms of the cost
implications of really there are ways to
make it work and I think you have models
that you can put five enormous palaces
or saying that that's what it needs to
be that's not what it needs to be do you
want to know what people think about
this yes are you go of paul asked sure
yes the House of Lords be based in New
York 23% said it should 36% said it
should not and 41% person into a granny
flats almost like getting a problem
can I bring in Lord Dobbs and he talks
about the Brazil and Australian model
other countries have moved part away
away from what is their main city and
made the capital elsewhere I came
Australia Canberra and so on and but in
Brazil you know we could manage that but
I think the important thing is keep
Parliament together as one entity both
houses of parliament we might have an
elected House of Lords I wouldn't mind
that but at least let's move Parliament
as a whole thing but main thing is to
give power to people in the north's
having Parliament sitting in one place
doesn't mean the power is going to be
there and I think the mayors of our
northern cities should have more power
more saying how they only come their
part of the country can I ask you
something and I'm sorry this is such a
conduit as you obviously and you're
quite rightly you're proud of your
northern roots
do you think they care do you think
people in the north would think
marvelous Lord what Tavish is going to
be coming to York next month I'm so
happy when you lock at the brexit vote
and I think that Lots the contributing
factors in the brexit vote there are so
many people that feel disenfranchised
that feel hardest hit by austerity that
feel that there's not opportunities in
their area so what I would say is it's
less about shoving than the Lord's
wherever it's more about as I said in
the thing it's got to be alongside a
program of particularly devolution
because why should any central hub say
in Westminster dictate and say well
Yorkshire well 1 Yorkshire there's big
campaigns for one your example to
devolve power at a separate government
for each John Prescott's idea of a
northern assembly or something died on
the vine but ultimately what do what do
a group of officials in Westminster know
about I don't know educational
priorities so in whole or local
infrastructure that's why you need a
good MP for whole setting them Michelle
you mentioned the bricks at vote as well
and you know this is another thing that
makes me excited about the post-break to
Eva we would have been discussing this
if the referendum hadn't happened it
would have been kind of Labour's
Heartland the north I never heard it I
never heard it during the play is and I
think that is part of this exciting
redrawing of the political maps play
their cards right over the next five
years I think they could keep hold of a
lot of a lot of these northern places
because we all talk about lending the
vote once I do think if they play the
cards right they could keep them on
going in labour would struggle so get
some of those seats back and you touched
on reform I made a note so you talk a
little bit about so you see regional
assemblies as part of that reform as
well because you don't just see the
House of Lords as the be-all and end-all
do you no but I would reform the House
of Lords I mean I think I'm just a bit
right down right well it's the world's
second biggest second chamber second
only after China is about eight eight
hundred of these people sitting there
getting this rendered quiz you've still
got in some cases
hereditary peers which I just think is
an absolute jerk and wrong so I think
there's so much you could actually do to
slim it down and make it more effective
before you just start
oil and sure we get to vote for Lord's
Island